i'll pull in sam i think he's been in
before so he says
uh what do you think of men and women's
relationships
are supposed to look like outside of sex
what does that time
in between look like is their whole
relationship
sexual in nature how do you believe sir
how do you balance learning skills
it seems once i focus a new one i lose
okay so let's pull them in
sam what's shaking dude any
clarification
yeah congratulations thanks man thank
you so clarification you wanna you wanna
talk about
uh women outside of when you're uh
grinding nasties in the bedroom on the
workbench
like what are you supposed to be doing
outside of that i'm more just kind of
wondering
what then are the interactions like even
if you're in an ltr
like this time you spend with the on a
woman
what does that look like it depends on
the relationship so are we talking about
ltr are we talking about a plate are we
talking about friends with benefits like
what are we talking about here
life it could be either or i mean like i
guess if you have a friends with
benefits then it's just strictly
uh hey we meet up and we we have sex
like that like that's strictly all it is
like if it's an fwb
you're not taking vacations together
she's not meeting your family
you know she's not showing up at
christmas or thanksgiving or anything
like that it's just
smash that's it right exactly are you
talking about a girlfriend here now or
not necessarily this is really just a
whole in general kind of uh
like you you could even apply this to
someone who you're not having a sexual
relationship with so you're just
wondering how to interact with women
that you're not
in a sexual relationship basically like
how do where do you place them in your
life or
is that what you're asking i'm just
simply wondering like how would do you
usually interact with
uh women i don't if if i'm not banging
why would i be
i mean we're either setting up the bank
or giving a question about whether or
not you're banging it's like let's say
you're
you are being a girl and let's say she's
a plate she's not necessarily friends
with benefits but you're
seeing her okay so so she's in rotation
then right i mean like you know you're
gonna see her on whatever you see her
and you got another girl later on in the
week because
you're a man of purpose and you're
chasing excellence you have things to do
with your day
you're not going on vacation with her
you're not spending a lot of time with
her
it's like you're getting to check her
out it's like a longer version of the
sniff test
did you read my book yes i did
phenomenal stuff
you know how in the book like i'm
talking about the first date is really
just a sniff test you know for an hour
yeah this is kind of like the longer
version of the sniff test this is where
you know where sean talks about in his
book the tactical guide to women he's
talking about basically
you know like you got a veteran over a
year year and a half to see what she's
really made of
you know apply some stress to it that's
really what you're doing right because
you're because your spinner is a plate
there's one or two
other women in rotation maybe you're
intimate with them maybe you're not
you you know you can do whatever you
want but you're basically seeing what
she's made out of
right so you know instead of just doing
the one hour date like you did the first
time maybe you're doing a little bit
longer it's like an evening
maybe there's a sleepover maybe you stay
over her place a little bit but nothing
you know that's that's like beyond days
right like you're not spending an entire
weekend together or anything like that
like she
she comes over friday after work and she
leaves monday morning right like that's
a girlfriend basically when you're
starting to do that
sam how old are you man if you don't
mind me asking 21.
all right yeah dude so right now you're
at the about near the lowest value
you'll ever be in your entire life
you know you know that right from what
rich talks about so you're just going to
increase value over time
a lot of this is because you don't see
your own value right now and what you
need to be doing to gain that value so
you're focused and worried about what
kind of time you should be sent spending
with women outside of the bedroom
and i get it you know you're figuring
your way out through this stuff so it's
not a big criticism
but like understand you can have
good interactions with women in social
circles and stuff like that like if i go
out on a friday night
you know i have women around me in fact
my friday night was me and three chicks
that was my friday night i had a great
time
you know there's time that i spend with
guys
you know what i mean that are my guy
time friends time there's times that i
might have a party or host something
women show up
guys girlfriends guys wives people i
work with
my assistant i just hired as a female
you know what i mean like
but the thing is that's in social time
social circles i'm sure
when rich goes to his boat club this
summer he's not gonna look at women that
are there and be like
i don't talk to you unless i'm trying to
bang it you know of course no he's not
he's
exactly but see rich is busy guy and
he's on his purpose so is he going to
text these girls for hours
and be like hey you know i'd like to get
to know you why don't we have a coffee
sort of thing you know
unless there's sex involved or wanting
yeah unless you're gonna lead up to
something like that
i should clarify i'm not looking to be
friends with girls at all that's not
i've realized first and foremost from my
education from first it's plate status
and then if you want to expand that then
you might want to ltr it could be
monogamous could be non-monogamous but
you don't promote her to an ltr until
she proves that that that she's worthy
of that right
meaning she's going to be a compliment
to your life not the focus
yeah and that's way down the road for me
right yeah so i mean it's just if you're
worried about like
oh man what rules do i follow so don't
spend too much time with this chick and
let it get too
deep or any of that stuff i think you're
kind of focused on the wrong thing
if you're focused on your purpose
getting to the gym
making money figuring you know figuring
that stuff out
then you see you're barely gonna have
time to see this chick
you're gonna see her when you can't see
her and sex is going to be involved and
the problem just takes care of itself
you know what i mean
she doesn't become this fixture in your
life that's there every single day
or whatever you know you don't have to
worry about setting those rules because
those rules will set themselves as you
as you focus on your on what you need to
do
if that makes sense which actually ties
into my second question which was about
learning skills finding the balance
of not losing one that you learn when
you start focusing on a new one for
instance
uh when i first got into like i found
rich
cooper's a channel like about two years
ago that pretty much was my whole
introduction to
everything red pill rolotomasi everyone
on rule zero and
my life could not be better for it so uh
basically after all that it was just how
to get the girls
basically um and developing that skill
and i've gone
you know for my age decent at it uh but
then i'm like okay what's really missing
is money that's what i should really be
focusing on and that's
uh and you know focusing on purpose as
we say you know chase excellence not
women
but what i've noticed is once i start
focusing on that a little bit
i lose the skill in just socializing
with women
so but once you've become a man of
purpose and have chase excellence and
have the results along with it
money changes a lot of things for you it
it creates a lot of options
um you don't there's a lot of these guys
that like manufacture this like thing
called game
you know where they make you memorize
lines and a lot of it's fake [ __ ]
you know yeah thank you fields and all
that yeah yeah yeah
but um it's really about setting
boundaries and enforcing them with women
you know when it comes to
longer term you know interactions when
you've when you've put your little dent
in the universe and that
you know that continues to grow the
point then is not to screw it up and
lose it and give half of it to her
you know there's and that's where game
you know comes into play but it's not
game like oh let me memorize this line
and
do like a redirect and do this and that
thing the other it's like no
it's do [ __ ] what it is that you're
on
and if there's some beautiful women
around you and you want to invite
one or two or three of them you know
into the into the mix
different times same time whatever the
hell it is that you're doing you can do
it
but understanding female psychology in
nature
is what we talk about is is what you
hear the rule zero guys talk about it's
what we
it's it's basically the underlying theme
of what gets you the results out of life
these guys that are that are that are
like banging on about
you know notch camps and stuff like this
like
look i would i would rather sit with
my buddy holt that's climb seven
mountains on seven different continents
and have conversations with him
than some guy that's like [ __ ] you
know hanging on to
a notch count number right you see what
i'm saying like
take take a little bit of the focus away
from women
move it more towards female psychology
and more importantly reallocate a lot of
that energy towards chasing excellence
and putting your dent in the universe
all that [ __ ] with checks you know
becomes really easy once you get to that
point
yeah plus so losing these skills it's
like man it's just your social
interactions so the essence of
kind of what makes my game or pick up if
we want to call it for lack of a better
term
different is it relies on a strong
internal framework right so you walk in
and you have a strong alpha framework to
begin with
so that's all the chasing excellent
stuff rich is talking about that's why
it goes really well with that
you know doing combat sports too being a
badass or a little bit you know what i'm
saying
just a little bit of getting back into
krav maga i used to do that back in high
school my friend and i he's doing it
over the summer i'm like we'll do it
when we get back to school
all that good stuff i frame is the
biggest thing that i need to
at least develop it's my biggest lacking
thing and reason being is just
through young life i didn't spend a lot
of time with men and didn't have
a lot of men or role models that were
good enough for that yeah
you didn't get to witness how to
communicate with women the way that
these measures
in general or in general right which
managing frame becomes a lot easier when
you become a man worthy
of managing said frame it's only been
better with
the uh shout out to rolo you know mental
point of origin
idea that's the only right slightly
better but i mean
yeah there's the mental part which is
the most important starting part part
it's like you act as if sort of thing
but there should be a transition to
becoming the game like to actually being
that mental point of origin
you see what i'm saying then i would
still need to transition into that and
that will happen over so you're 21 dude
like
you know fine cool awesome just you know
keep keep
working you know towards your purpose
putting that dent in the universe
chasing excellence make that important
i'm not saying don't date women don't
don't definitely don't get into a
long-term monogamous relationship in
your 20s
right i've read your unless she's
then you should be like paul and then
marry her right marry her single mother
yeah 45 years old
at least two kids in tow you know at
least three different things
even better yeah yeah that'd be perfect
from two different fathers or
all three of them yeah hey what's your
uh what's your what are you working
towards what's your vocation
uh funny enough uh long-term uh
fictional author but i have ideas for
uh i want to start business when i start
building capital for
something in fashion and uh i have
considered and i think because my friend
he
basically i uh i don't claim to be a red
pill evangelist or anything like that
but
i kind of introduced him to some some of
this stuff and he's like dude this is so
awesome you're
and he kind of inspired me to actually
want to start another channel which i'm
researching that as well
and that's just for fun like how you
were explaining earlier uh i've been
looking at that for a while
um so going into that i'm currently i
just got on an on-boarding process for
uh i've a background the past two years
of phone sales
and high ticket sales and i in the past
year i've gone a little bit to
copywriting so i want to focus on those
two skills specifically
to uh start something so all right so
your practice on female game is just
like sales skills man
it really is they're flying into you you
get rid of your
self take yourself out of the equation
because you're just a badass all right
you already know it
and then you climb into her brain and
you figure out what are her
thoughts feelings emotions perspectives
trigger points
and you communicate to that part of her
brain to move things along to where you
want it to go
it's just like sales and of course if
the product is not for her
or if she's not qualified for the
product you don't try to sell it to her
right
move to the next one it's the same thing
and when you interact with women on a
regular basis
you just interact with them you're not
trying to necessarily sleep with all
these women like you go to a party or
something that someone's throwing
you're just talking to women that's a
chance for you to work on these
communication skills
with no pressure of closing or trying to
make those things happen
and that way those skills develop you
know and that way you're not losing
when someone tells me i'm losing my
skills that tells me you're focused on a
goal like getting a girl's number sleep
with her whatever
and and then you're you're falling on
your face right instead of just worried
about this communication connection
and working on those what we could call
sales skills right with these women and
that'll
help you throughout as you sell things
and build businesses and do whatever
to communicate with women you know in
the marketplace
of whatever you're trying to sell is
pretty important you know what i'm
saying so they
do go in hand actually i mean the
biggest thing sales gave to me was
uh being able to handle rejection yeah
thank you
you